[Music]
joining me now is Priyanka Vergara a
customer engineer at Google cloud who's
going to show us how to develop for
kubernetes without leaving your IDE
thanks for being here thank you for
having me I'm gonna talk about
communities and how developers can work
within the original studio environment
and deploy applications into kubernetes
so let's jump right in great cool so I
have on the left-hand side my terminals
which we're gonna use to do some
deployment and then on the right here I
have Visual Studio code so we're going
to start off by creating a new
application let's just create a hello
world nodejs application nothing fancy
so what's happening here is we should be
able to see our application create it
once i refresh it is showing up my
application I have the source files the
front end and the back end are the
different services that are in this
application in the front end we have the
8080 port that's listening to the front
end it's talking to the back end on
back-end service address and in the back
end we have the index file that's also
talking to 8080 so we're going to change
that to 80 81 so that we can we don't
have a port conflict and then at this
point if we go into go and start these
services I'm going to just check where
we are in our terminal we're at the
right place in the front end folder and
we want to do the same for our back end
as well so I'm gonna go into the right
folder which is the HelloWorld node.js
application - and then so we're now in
backends and front front-end folders now
if we run npm install' that's gonna get
us all the dependencies that it needs to
to run the run both our front-end and
back-end services and then once that is
done we need to stir these services so
our back-end is running on a DAT one and
a front ends running on 8080 so we're
ready to test our application
our back-end is only 81 and our front
end is on 8080 talking to our back-end
so we have an application that's running
through Visual Studio code now at this
point if I wanted to deploy this
application into into gke I would first
need a cluster to create and then once
the prospect roster is created then I
can start deploying this application so
let's see how we how we can create a
cluster from within Visual Studio code I
have the extension for for Visual Studio
code called code gke extension and once
you download that extension you'll start
to see your projects and your custer's
in the in your ID environment I'm going
to just use my current one of the
current projects and create create a
cluster in the current project so my
current project is KQ demo and so we'll
set that as a project ID and then I'll
use it gives me an option to select the
zones and then here we're just gonna say
test as a cluster name and then there's
the number of nodes that you want to
create that you can change and then also
the machine types we're just gonna go
with the standard and click create once
I do that it takes a maybe three or four
minutes to actually create the cluster
it's spinning up all these instances in
Google Cloud for you and if i refresh
this you should be able to see that it's
starting to bring up the test cluster
right here it's orange because it's not
set up yet so give it a few minutes and
it starts to set up at this point we're
gonna just use for the demo purpose the
cluster that I already have created and
we'll go through the demo using that
cluster now once I have the cluster I'm
ready to deploy and I need a scaffold
yamo to actually deploy in the cluster
okay and for those who might not have
heard of scaffold what is that
so scaffold is basically a command line
tool that lets you define your
kubernetes manifest it also defines the
container registries and then for the
back end and the front
especially for our application here so
if you have a large number of services
that are run in your application you
would define your container registry
addresses in there and would pick up
from from those from those addresses and
deploy your service in GK right yeah so
let's see an example of that so I'm just
first going to go through deployment I
think I forgot to set the cluster so
let's first set this cluster once it is
set then we're going to deploy take the
deploy and do that starting to deploy
while it's deploying let's look at our
scaffold yeah mo this is the amulet is
talking about where you have the back
end and the front end and GC r dot io
addresses which is the container
registry address and then the manifest
for your kubernetes and it seems like we
have our application deployed so let's
see the IP address that's the IP address
of our application and it's the one that
we just created and we see that the
application is working on port 4,000 so
our front end is talking to our back-end
both of them now deployed on a GK
cluster so we did all of that from our
IDE and yeah that's fantastic I guess
the next step that I would think of is
making changes to let's say our back-end
without affecting our front-end so for
example what if I want to test to make
sure that my change doesn't break
anything without needing to redeploy
redeploy and rebuild that's a great
point because is it in a development
lifecycle that's the biggest you know
hurdle you test you to you develop your
test and then you want to deploy that
but but the test stage is a very
critical stage so you would use
something called telepresence for that
and telepresence is again a command-line
tool that helps you create a proxy so in
this case in this example what we're
going to do is create a proxy and create
our and run our back-end on local
machine and then our front-end would
continue to run on our GK cluster in
production so we're able to test the
changes to our back-end but our
front-end stays intact okay so let's see
that yeah so in this case here so when
you come out of this and let's see where
we are I want to go into the application
that we just deployed which is this and
let's make a little bit of a change here
in our front-end application so that we
can use a little bit of a so but the I
just called it version 2 for our
back-end and at this point if I run my
telepresence command which is nothing
but it creates a proxy and it's going to
run it on port so here it is it's
forwarding the ports now and if we go
test our back-end and on a local machine
that's going to version 2 and it should
work the same way from our front end as
well so that's that's pretty much how it
works very impressive so we were not
only able to see you being able to
redeploy using your local IDE to gke
using cloud code and scaffold but you
were also able to make changes locally
to a single service test it and then
again redeploy to gke was pretty
powerful yeah telepresence ok well thank
you so much again for joining us
thank you for having me
[Music]
you
[Music]